but like speaking of super addicted fan
bases like
i'm i used to think that way about the
naruto fan base
yeah right because i was never in the
naruto fan base i never got into naruto
as much as
yeah other people did but as you said
the moment boruto dropped
excuse me i'm a naruto fan yeah i don't
want to watch [ __ ]
foreign video on why
naruto's power scaling is the most
perfectly balanced thing in existence
there's i see a lot of those videos
popping my recommended that are like uh
i don't know what's [ __ ] some
character i don't know like
madro has had his name yeah yeah
character it'll be like i remember
there's like a
90 minute video i recommended that was
like why his power was the best and i'm
like
this is 90 minutes long what the [ __ ]
yeah they go through every single
scenario of moderator and that's cool
because i think i think it's great that
like i imagine uh i mean like you want
to i see a jojo video that's super in
depth
yeah that's [ __ ] sick but then i'm
from the outside looking in it's like
whoa that seems so excessive
yeah yeah i guess it's really [ __ ]
awesome if you're in the fandom yeah but
you could say that about any fandom but
like
what what like i don't understand is
like how how
the like how a lot of the fandom still
has like so much momentum yeah that's
even off even like after the series has
ended because you normally think of an
army series after it ends
there's like this cool off period yeah
and it kind of like goes into like
memory and everything right
with a lot of like the biggest shown in
titles even if they've ended it's weird
yeah really weird like i'm genuinely
like curious how they've
been able to maintain their momentum
yeah i'm jealous i'm like how do you
keep coming up with this content
yeah before like like i can't do that
like that naruto youtubers yeah yeah
yeah it's kind of i mean i admire it man
like i mean the fact that you can still
keep an audience going
uh it's it's honestly it's admirable
because most of the time they just talk
about the show yeah so like because and
like
the audience that just does not lose
that passion no matter
how much time has passed no matter how
many new series has come out this they
still
like would will consume all their all
this stuff where there's like no new
media coming out because the manga ended
like
what like four or five years ago or
something it was a long time ago
which one are we talking about naruto
yeah it was a while ago and it's funny
because all the
all of the narrative videos i've seen
are just on like the naruto segment part
yeah nobody's talking about bodybuilding
no one's talking about no one gives a
[ __ ] about borrow
exactly i mean i like those kind of
videos i think
okay going back to dragon ball i just
had a [ __ ] flashback i remember this
one channel i don't know what it's
called and i'm sorry if you're watching
this
there was a guy who made uh like fights
between dragon ball characters
and his oc and this channel had like
tons of videos and had like 200k subs i
think
and i was like this is insane like
people are thousands of people are
watching
a dude's oc fight dragon ball characters
i'm like that's so funny i okay you kind
of i can understand why you might be
interested in a death battle
between uh i mean i think it's known
characters
that's okay that's cool you want to see
the outcomes but when it's someone's oc
i i was like my mind was blown i was
like wait people are into this this is
this is how desperate people are for for
dragon ball content
and like it's so funny okay i'll give
the naruto people props at least they
have like
the majority of the content that seems
to be doing really well is the content
that is like
50 minute analysis videos i'm sure you
love that if you're into it but yeah
you know i mean i i find it like what's
more entertaining than the content
itself for me
is watching people react to the content
oh my gosh because it's like
okay so i remember i did like an
attitude rewind and people were like
asking me why i put like double for
anime
in like the anishiev one it's cause he's
the legend because
how are you not entertained watching a
shirtless dude scream his [ __ ] ass
off
watching goku versus what was it like it
was naruto vs naruto versus uh
goku i think i think it was narrative
versus ichigo maybe something like that
yeah
versus ichigo and he was just shirtless
bringing his arsenal he wasn't shirtless
he wasn't shirtless he was he didn't
have a shirt on but he had this massive
scarf on for some reason
without a shirt i'm like that's an
interesting fashion statement oh it's
just not entertaining to you
i respect that man that sounds like
great content it was [ __ ] hilarious
because
because i found out about that video
through the anitune rewind and i'm like
i have to go watch this video
so i found it and i watched the entire
thing i'm like this is the best
entertainment
yeah this entire week yeah because it's
so hilarious just he was screaming at
the top of his voice like a [ __ ]
ten-year-old girl
and so excited by the fact that naruto
won i'm like damn i wish i could get
that excited about a [ __ ]
battle right that's so admirable i wish
i could get that excited about anything
i know right
man i i feel like naruto fans are just
like toned down dragon ball fans to some
extent
i feel like i feel like in terms of like
passion and like like the
cultness of it is what i'm going to call
i guess it's like dragon ball is
definitely
up there at the top of just passionate
dedicated fans i think every anime fan
base is just
i think dragon version of the track yeah
i think dragon ball is by far the most
like
aggressive and like oh yeah this is what
we want but it's funny because like
dragon ball is pretty much as close to a
mainstream anime
as you can get yeah yeah but there's
there's a difference between people who
know dragon ball
and people who are anime fans who also
grew up with dragon ball
and then just dragon ball fans and then
you are dragon ball oh you know because
they'll be at the gym wearing some goku
[ __ ] or something oh yeah yeah of course
you'll bench push me yeah yeah the
[ __ ] goku goku under armour [ __ ]
the perfect analogy for the dragon ball
fandom yeah it's just if tyler1 was
abandoned
that's just like i love tyler
but it's so true though i wouldn't be
surprised if tyler won as a dragon ball
fan
he likes anime yeah tyler one come on
the podcast please come back
oh my god i need a monkey brain here